Estados Unidos vivirá una vida más fría
en cuatro décadas casi todos los estados
del país sienten los estragos de la gran
tormenta invernal Elliot la cual deja
más de 90 millones de personas en alerta
máxima principalmente en el medio oeste
y la región de los grandes lagos por lo
que las autoridades han estado a sus
ciudadanos a tomarse en serio la
tormenta
no es un día de nieve normal como cuando
eran niños en serio y mi equipo está
listo para ayudar a las comunidades a
sobrellevar esta tormenta
se espera que Durante los próximos días
Elliot se convierta en una bomba
ciclónica con ráfagas de viento tan
fuertes que pueden alcanzar el
equivalente a un huracán categoría 3
provocando hasta 30 centímetros de nieve
y temperaturas entre los 10 y los 20
grados bajo cero este jueves Más de
2.200 vuelos fueron cancelados y se
espera que la situación empeore tanto en
las vías como en los aeropuertos siendo
una de las festividades en las que los
estadounidenses más se movilizan debido
a que tenemos que mover más despacio
tenemos que establecer programar o
reducir nuestro horario
ha sido un poco loco llegué temprano
para asegurarme de tomar mi vuelo y a la
puerta de embarque cuando me enteré que
Fue cancelado las aerolíneas
estadounidenses anunciaron que trabajan
para que Los viajeros puedan reunirse en
Navidad y eliminarán las tarifas de
cambio a Los afectados por la tormenta